[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily for
the gabby patino family versus the brian
laundry family they made that very
callous
that very
terrible statement
giving hope to joe and nicole that
perhaps gabby was still alive with full
knowledge that she was not could a
simple suit be headed for trial and
knowing
the individual's background
has to have something to do with why
we're all here
so you have to take that into
consideration i guess a date is set and
jury selection enters its final stretch
for the penalty phase of the parkland
school shooter plus the men are the
direction was it
in a front to back downward motion
um i would presume it's front to back
conflicting testimony on how a beloved
pet was shot as candy the dog civil
trial is back in session and later what
it would take for amber her to appeal
when that is entered meaning stamp filed
in her court that's when the 30 days
start ticking our legal analysts break
down the appeal process law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer nearly one
year after gabby petito and brian
laundry took an ill-fated road trip
across the country their parents face
off in a florida courtroom
gabby petito made national headlines
last fall after she was reported missing
in early september her family told
officials she had been on a
cross-country road trip with her fiance
brian laundry petito's body was later
found in grand teton national park her
cause of death was ruled to be
strangulation after a weeks-long manhunt
longi's remains were discovered in a
florida reserve authorities determined
he died by suicide along with his
remains investigators found a written
confession where laundry admitted to
killing potito months later petito's
parents filed a civil suit against chris
and roberto laundry arguing brian
laundry told his parents about potato's
murder in late august of last year and
that they later helped conceal his
location before he went missing on
wednesday with the patino family
appeared in a florida courtroom for a
motion hearing the laundries did not
appear to be did not appear but were
represented by an attorney who argued
the laundries had a right not to speak
up under the fifth amendment the potato
family attorney then countered saying
the laundry's actions gave the potatoes
false hope
conduct that amounts to remaining silent
and maintaining privacy
is not intentional infliction of
emotional distress
and there are no cases where such
conduct was found to be intentional
infliction of emotional distress
rather plaintiffs argue that the
laundries had an obligation a duty to
speak
the law imposes no such obligation to
speak they knew starting on august 28th
of 2021 that gabby was dead
they knew where gabby's body was they
knew that the potito family was
desperately searching for information
but they did things affirmatively they
didn't just remain silent
brian laundry came home
in gabby petito's van by himself to his
family's home
that family knowing
that gabby was dead
knowing their son had murdered her
knowing where the body was and in
particular knowing that joseph petito
and nicole schmidt were desperate to
learn where their daughter was located
they went on vacation
they assumed and continued their normal
life as though nothing had happened
while this family was suffering wanting
to know what their daughter where their
their daughter was
the judge said he will make a ruling in
the next two weeks as to whether the
case goes to trial right now it's set to
be tried in august of next year
joining us today is former swat and
detective lisa lockwood and co-host
terry austin lisa if the potato family
ultimately wins the lawsuit does doesn't
mean that going forward people will have
an affirmative duty to report any
information they have about a crime
i think this will set a new precedent if
we do get a win in this case and that
precedent would be civilly that people
are liable will be hold liable
for compensatory damages
if they do not
if they are not for forthcoming with
information regarding a crime this
particular case they the assumption is
they knew what brian did they knew where
gabby gabby's body was and they
completely stonewalled
her her family and this was a close
relation
relationship prior to that so civilly it
may hold up because it appears all of it
appears from the outside to be an
intentional infliction of distress
emotional distress on this family
because they had information that could
have helped find their daughter a lot
sooner and they fail to do so well
here's hoping this goes to trial so we
can unearth a lot of these facts terry
the attorneys on both sides made strong
arguments which side had the better ones
though
you know what brian they both made very
strong arguments the potatoes are trying
to show that there was intentional
infliction of emotional distress as lisa
mentioned and in order to show that
they're going to have to show that the
laundry family they acted intentionally
and recklessly that it was extreme and
it was outrageous and that they caused
that severe emotional distress they
argued a lot about what is outrageous
behavior and the judge asked some very
difficult questions he asked both
attorneys information about the case so
we'll see what happens but i do hope it
goes to trial and i do think the judge
is going to allow it to get to that
point yeah i want to know how when
do they know exactly that gabby petita
was dead and what do they do these are
some major facts and information of
course we'll bring to you if and when
this case goes to trial switching now to
celebrity legal news for the first time
since a verdict is handed down we're
hearing from the spokesperson of
comedian bill cosby earlier this week
cosby was found liable in a decades-old
sexual assault case brought by now 64
year old judy huff she claims the
comedian sexually assaulted her at the
playboy mansion in the 1970s when she
was just 16 years old it's the first
time the civil case has made it to trial
since cosby was released a year ago
after his criminal conviction for a
sexual assault alleged by a different
woman was overturned late tuesday
afternoon jurors awarded huff
500 000 in damages but no punitive
damages were awarded while kazi was not
present for the trial or the verdict his
spokesperson says the famed actor viewed
the verdict as a win
the five hundred thousand dollars
was a huge victory for us and the reason
why i say that
is because
they could have given her unlimited
damages and punitive damages and it did
not which told us that yes they wanted
to punish mr cosby the jurors
and we found out from juror number two
and juror number three who spoke with mr
cosby that many of the jurors came in
with a bias against him um many of the
jurors came in saying we have daughters
and uh
we just think he should be punished but
they didn't feel that judith huff
um
really reached her burden
still ahead on law and crime daily the
candy the dog civil trial resumes after
several delays due to coving
but first we head to florida where
opening statements will soon be
presented in the penalty phase of the
parkland school shooter
[Music]
welcome back after nearly three months
of jury selection and several setbacks a
new date is scheduled for the penalty
phase trial for the parkland school
shooter back in october he pled guilty
to killing 17 people in the february
2018 mass shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in parkland florida
the incident sparked nationwide
conversations about gun control measures
and mental health a jury made up of 12
people will decide whether the 23 year
old should spend the rest of his life in
prison or be put to death jurors will
consider whether several aggravating
factors including his planning and
cruelty outweigh his history of mental
and emotional problems on wednesday
judge elizabeth schreier signed an order
to begin opening statements two and a
half weeks later than planned as
attorneys work to narrow down the jury
dozens of potential jurors enter the
final round of questioning this week
attorneys asked potential jurors about
considering the defendant's background
if they are chosen
after
looking at these 17 sets of crime scene
and autopsy photos right
for many people
and rightfully so
the background history of the person
that did that
doesn't matter anymore my fear is
once you've seen those photos
and you're really not going to consider
the guilty murderer's background in your
punishment decision
is that
a valid fear for me to have i can
understand your fear
but
knowing
that the individual's background
has to have something to do with why
we're all here
so you have to take that into
consideration i guess in other words the
events that took
place is why we're here and
the individual that did that that
obviously um
we have to learn all the information and
i'm sure his background has something to
do with it
we would have to
take all the evidence in and weigh it
opening statements are now scheduled to
begin july 6th testimony expected to
last for four months
terry this mass shooting has sparked
discussion about gun control do you
think this case will actually change gun
control legislation
you know brian unfortunately i don't
think they're going to be any changes at
all we've already seen on the federal
level that the bill before the house and
the senate it's already watered down
there are no bans on assault weapons no
bans on bump stocks no bans on
high-capacity magazines
and we already saw today the u.s supreme
court struck down new york's gun law
which says you can't carry a concealed
weapon that that's a violation of the
second amendment and we've had that law
in place for years so i don't think
these mass shootings are going to change
anything at all as far as the
legislation is concerned on the state or
federal level yeah now lisa with these
mass shootings and and the legislation
in this and this
national discussion
do you think uh that these string of
shootings will affect jury selection
process or even the death penalty phase
for the shooter here
well i don't we've had the death penalty
for for for decades and there has never
been a deterrent or a lower crime
statistic based on having death
penalties in various states especially
when somebody has mental or
psychological issues it's not even a
thought they will go ahead and do what
they are planning to do without thinking
about the consequences so i don't see
that as a deterrent going forward um but
uh death penalty i've had issue going
back and forth i'm i'm glad i'm not
sitting on that jury right now i would
agree with you on i mean i always agree
with you lisa but definitely on that
point as well well coming up on law and
crime daily johnny depp and amber
heard's teams are due back in court plus
closing arguments inch closer in the
candy the dog civil trial out of florida
[Music]
welcome back a veterinarian takes a
stand in the so-called candy the dog
civil trial just before the defense
arrested in a florida courtroom the case
surrounded surrounds an incident in 2016
when zach diederly shot candy rodney
jacobson's terrier mix deterly claimed
the dog was in an attack stance when he
shot her local officials say dieterle
was not charged because he had a right
to carry the weapon
in that he had a permit and that he was
within his rights to use deadly force
because he feared for his life jacobson
says candy had no history of aggression
this week the case was forced to take a
several day break due to multiple jurors
testing positive for coven 19. the trial
resumed thursday with the final
witnesses testifying for the defense
including a veterinarian who told jurors
a different story from a previous
witness last week dr wendy ellis said
the bullet that killed candy traveled
left to right which is inconsistent with
what a veterinarian said on the stand
the thursday are the direction was it uh
in a front to back downward motion
um i would presume it's front to back
because if the entry hole is in the
chest
um
and the bullet ended up going into the
abdomen then that's front to back there
was a
veterinarian that testified in this case
that the bullet traveled the midline
from the
left side of the dog to the right side
of the dog but that would be
inconsistent with
your findings and your surgical
procedures with the dog correct um from
my up report i don't see
necessarily anything that went to the
right side of the dog i didn't have any
damage there but
i would say it would went from the left
side
in from the chest into the abdomen and
not necessarily in
out the right side but definitely around
the abdomen which could include going
over to the right side to some degree
i don't know what bullets do once they
enter the body and i heard they ricochet
a little bit
all right terry we now have conflicting
reports from the veterinarians regarding
how the bullet traveled how do you think
the jury will consider that information
you know sometimes the jury ignores
expert opinions especially when they
conflict with each other they sort of
cancel the other out i think the jury's
going to be focusing on a couple of
things here first of all they're going
to have to determine whether or not
candy the dog was aggressive and whether
or not deedee lee and this is the
important issue was he afraid for his
life if the answer to both those
questions is yes then i do think deterly
will be the victor in this case i think
what the jury is also going to look at
is
did he shoot after the dog after it ran
away that's going to help them determine
whether or not he really was in fear of
his life yeah now lisa you have a well
of knowledge on this of course law
enforcement works with canines they come
in contact with dogs and you're a dog
mom yourself so based on your expertise
should dearly have done what he did in
shooting the dog or should he have done
something different
i 100
support deter lee only because
as a police officer responding to scenes
i was bit twice i did not have any
opportunity to respond to get pepper
spray to get my bat to even pull my gun
it happened so quickly and when he
explained that he had an opportunity to
stop on the ground to try to make the
dog stop it wouldn't stop he even kicked
he made contact with the dog's head the
dog was still coming at him and
aggressing and he was down to his last
resort which was pulling his gun and
protecting himself one last thing brian
four and a half million americans are
bit every single year 65 percent of
those dog bites come from the pit bull
breed so you have an intrinsic fair fear
with pit bull bulls across america so i
think that's going to help him in this
case yeah that fact will definitely be
used in his defense or his argument and
it might further his case
well when we come back johnny depp
versus amber heard what to expect from
friday's hearing and what it would take
for her to file an appeal
[Music]
welcome back johnny depp and amber
heard's team are headed back to court
for a hearing on friday early this month
a virginia jury largely sided with
johnny depp in the defamation case scene
around the world depp sued ex-wife amber
heard for 50 million dollars claiming
she defamed him as an abuser in a 2018
washington post op-ed heard fired back
with a hundred million dollar
countersuit alleging depp physically and
sexually assaulted her after six weeks
of testimony including from both deaf
and heard jurors awarded johnny depp 50
million dollars in damages amber heard
was awarded 2 million dollars for
statements made by depp's attorney
heard was not awarded any punitive
damages though during friday's hearing
judge penny alex karate will enter the
judgment
time will also be set aside to discuss
other issues following the verdict herds
attorney indicated she planned to file
an appeal in the case law and crime
legal analyst catherine lozardo explains
what it would take under virginia law
for that appeal to be filed
first of all she has to file a notice of
appeal and in virginia she has 30 days
from the date that the judgment is
entered to file a notice of appeal it's
not 30 days from the date that the jury
reached a verdict and the judgment is
the written order that the judge will
enter in this case when the jury reached
their verdict judge as karate said to
ben chu please go ahead and write the
order and then what johnny depp's legal
team will do is they'll write that
judgment and then show it to amber's
legal team and there will be a lot of
back and forth objections as to how it
should be worded and then it'll be given
to judges karate for final approval and
then she will sign it and enter it as
the final judgment in the trial court
only when that is entered meaning stamp
filed in her court that's when the 30
days start ticking for amber heard to
file a document called a notice of
appeal together with the notice of
appeal amber heard must also post an
appeal bond appeal bond is 500
or such some as the trial court may
require subject to subsection e of that
code section and that subsection e code
section there's a lot of different rules
there but what i wanted to point out is
the subsection e just basically says if
a party files a motion for the bond to
be increased or decreased then the trial
court would have to consider that motion
and resolve it or modify the 500
all right lisa terry's going to talk to
us about this upcoming hearing but i
want to ask you beyond this hearing with
all these interviews and media coverage
do you think this would be the last we
hear of johnny depp and amber heard
no hardly brian uh we're there's talks
right now of amber writing a book we
have the appeal going forward she's been
cut out of aquaman she needs to make
money johnny's running around on his
rock and roll victory tour lap right now
so i would imagine that this continued
kind of uh live action soap
opera is far from over it's kind of a
gift that keeps on giving but i want to
return it
terry the trial is over and the verdict
has reached what are we our expectations
for this upcoming hearing what i'm
expecting is that the judgment is going
to be entered and as we heard it is
drafted generally by the prevailing
party agreed upon by the losing party
and then it's entered by the judge and
there is really no opportunity to change
the jury's decision but i mean we could
hear at the hearing that there's some
discussion about settlement and that
could very well be the case they could
settle they could come to an agreement
but at that hearing the judge is
absolutely going to enter the verdict
the verdict that the jury gave you can
only set aside a verdict if there's
weight against the evidence and and
there are reasons to set it aside so
there's going to be the judgment it's
going to be entered and then there may
or may not be a settlement all right may
or may not we'll see how this plays out
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you